it's the fighter and the kid had to run
it back cause we back at it again yeah
we gon keep it moving like it's never
gonna end when it was brendan when it
was brian when he was just talking to
friends we got the kid calling on the
left with the fighter on the right had
to do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
we're out come on baby
let's go dude how could his chin look
today chin is tight you look like you're
you look like you're the guy who's gonna
come and rob a museum with me and then i
go
great love the look but you can't wear
khaki and maroon oh i like the khaki no
i do too but i need him in black because
we're going to be doing this tonight and
that kind of stands out but i like the
look it looks like the brain's the
operation yeah if you're gonna rob like
an art gallery yeah yeah you look like
the fast the guy who's a thief but also
fashion conscious and you want to mix it
up and i'm like not today
this is a huge heist
who the [ __ ] robs
some people rob like museums is that a
thing do people actually still
uh didn't yeah someone jack
someone jacked some big art piece
recently i thought right where do you
sell it if it's a big art piece like you
got to find some billionaire who's
willing to pay for it yeah and hang it
up in there but also how's the
billionaire find that art piece
is he on like the dark web like i'll
take the mona lisa i guess but then i'm
weird cops are like but that's that
that you're a billionaire so you're
you gotta hope your your kids friends
don't come over like snapchat or tick
tock the mona lisa right you'd be
stressed out the entire time a little
bit or you have like a uh like a
christmas party
like your aunt from wherever flies in
you hope that [ __ ] doesn't start
snitching
like he has the mona lisa on his house
then it starts spreading thinking about
authority there's a guy i a friend of my
parents who
had a
relic it was like a spear from the
amazon
that he bought down there but it was an
authentic spear from like this the
yanomamo tribe or something like that
and
think about how shitty people are he has
this big party
um he's got made money and he he does a
lot of charity work so he had this big
party for charity like he was trying to
raise fundraising and the spirit's just
in the house like chilling with the
spirits just on the wall like a
centerpiece yeah just on the wall
a guy
see someone saw someone
and said that feather
the feathers are are um
from uh an endangered bird and they're
not allowed to be in this country i'm
going to report him
and reports him anonymously i bet you
that guy is the guy that leaves so many
yelp reviews well he's a whoever it was
was a an enemy of this guy because
or just a
piece of piece of [ __ ] yeah a piece of a
cowardly little like weasel you know is
it guy leaves a a
comment on pornhub or something yeah
exactly same guy exactly just it has a
just an account to like oh man that
scene where he did and another thing i
don't like about this man it's hot all
that
you know well the guy so check this out
or he's are you jesus but let me finish
this like man his hands are too small
but let me finish the story so he goes
so
he
does that and the [ __ ] guy uh it cost
him
one million dollars
one
million dollars in fines and lawyers
fees to defend himself oh you oh because
he has all the money so he's like i'll
fight this yeah but no he had to fight
it he had to fight it because we got
prison time they brought the hammer of
the gods down on him because he was
wealthy what a waste of time in taxes
but that's what they do
so he spent one million dollars
getting himself in the clear and it took
over a year it took two years i think
yeah finance to keep that stupid stick
but also i won't here's my thing that
guy
imagine this be let's say you were like
some big like animal person and he
walked in my house and i have a giant
taxidermied [ __ ] white elephant
that's the last one on earth yeah
right and you and you were appalled
you're like mother what the this is the
last one like yeah cool right yeah he
got a cold passed away dude i said go
ahead and box that thing up ship it to
my house imagine that he's young he's
young and just shot him he was just in
the way well i'd be like what do you
want me to do i didn't kill him man it's
cool art right you know like go ahead
and push that button makes a noise you
know like it's just some
outlandish bill in their [ __ ]
and you're you're like offended
tell me
who would you call to report that
what do you call the elephant society
would you google it i wouldn't endanger
animal
hotline yeah would you who would he call
i wouldn't
did you call your local cops i'm like uh
okay yeah
we're trying to solve murder too there
are 500 cold cases dude we're gonna [ __ ]
with this they'll put you through to
like you know the protective species
bureau that's what you do
social media
take a picture of unreal you believe
this last one on earth piece of [ __ ]
somebody help me take this guy out oh my
god
and then you'd get a million social
justifiers like get up you just have a
million people in general
hollywood everybody would be like this
[ __ ] killing elephants some
famous celeb would be like can you
believe that well no what happens in
that situation is people who are public
figures
they want to up their profile but
expressing their outrage they use you
for social currency and they ruin you i
can't believe they killed an elephant
you know i don't want to kill elephants
either but like they'll just some people
will just this is my chance to get more
attention my chance to get more social
credit by ruining this guy's life which
is why i don't believe those i'll tell
you right right now though if i had that
if you walked in my house tomorrow if i
had a dinner party and there was a spare
on the wall
i would lie my i'd be like did that kill
a thousand men man yeah i bought it at
the flea market yeah i thought you think
killed a thousand man yeah that's what
i'll tell you
one thousand the story would change
every time pierced the sides of 1 000
men like dude that you have you seen the
movie 300 like yeah like you know the
sperry throws in it you know that's a
movie but that's the uh real experiment
yeah check out uh now what would you
what's the best let me see let me test
your your historical knowledge you got a
spear up there
what is the what's the actual thing if
you really wanted to lie
and you what's what would be the most
famous spear you could ever possess well
i'd say you know achilles is right the
greek clothes keep going like you know
how they say it's all mythical
nope it's not man nope that's nice i get
it off the dark way all you [ __ ]
listen
hold on help me out here spear yeah it's
a spear give me time period if you had a
spear up on the wall and you wanted to
come up with the greatest story what
would be the most valuable spear you
could ever own there's a spear that we
just used on someone in history it was
you it was spear it was a spear that was
used on someone that if you had that
spear
people would come from all over the
world what from all over the world
to pay homage and this is world history
yes people would come from all over the
world no think about it
if i had a spear on my wall and they and
people believed it was the actual spear
used to pierce this particular person
people from all over the world would
come
and kneel
is it kneeling that's biblical
sure
is it mythology or no it's biblical
biblical yeah biblical society old
school sort of what's the spear you
[ __ ] what is it
not the one that killed jesus yes it's
the well it's the it's the spirit that
the roman lee uh uh centurion or
whatever used to pierce jesus's side
when he was crucified when they're up
there they picked oh he got pierced in
the side holy lands also called the
spear of destiny
yeah
oh you you
i mean you kind of have that in your
house it's the landscape you have
millions of people like coming to kiss
the spin of course you can have that
it's the lance that pierced the side of
jesus
now listen i don't have the holy spirit
but i'm damned closer to firing kid fan
your boy has been working relentlessly
relentlessly yeah to get the fine kid 3d
original episodes back and guess what as
of this morning daddy got them all back
you got them from fox sports
the team has them we've got all 12
episodes and outtakes which i didn't
know they had they had out there and we
were in our 20s when we did that dude we
did that when we were 17. let's release
that they're in black and white dude so
i have all 12 episodes uh people shout
out to pete valencia who was our boss at
fox sports who actually greenlit the the
whole operation yeah and i ran into him
at uh malibu cars and coffee with my
kiddos he's got a an older ferrari dope
ass ferrari
and i was talking and he was like yeah
and his buddy was like oh how do you
know him he's like oh we actually this
project getting fired kid 3d and i go
and he goes whatever happened though so
i'm like that's why i wanted to see you
dude i want those he's like you do i'm
like yes
and he's like fox doesn't care they're
doing nothing with it i'm like you think
they would release them he's like i can
make some calls just have friends over
there and then we exchange numbers and
then just weeks months
yeah pete hit me up with today and was
like yo
sending you all 12 episodes right now
are you serious just sign this contract
i'm like yes
not to pay 10 million dollars 10 million
dollars but this i think we release them
i think every tuesday
we drop yeah for the next 12 weeks an
episode of fire and kit 3d great 12
episodes 13th episode be the outtakes
we'll create sizzles put on fighting
with the kid but it'll all be on fire
kid youtube great idea would be cool huh
i love it we'll just start it tomorrow i
love that yeah the first episode came
out tomorrow so for those who didn't see
it or had to pay for it or you illegally
streamed it
now you can watch it it's very real
at firing the kid uh youtube
how was yours how was indiana
dude fort wayne was awesome great clubs
that summit comedy club the same owners
as brickstown spokane and tacoma yep
just like that family owned they run a
good club i guess it was called gut
busters before like rodney dangerfield
some [ __ ] came through like old school
but uh
it's just you know it's uh they're they
just they're appreciative i didn't
realize how close fort wayne is to
everything like a lot of fans i'd meet
they're like oh i go where'd you come
from drove from chicago where'd you come
from detroit
where'd you come from michigan which
come from uh you know ohio it's kind of
like either it might make more sense to
fly to chicago and then drive or
somewhere oh we looked at it uh so you
you could fly into chicago or detroit
like a two and a half hour drive or you
can fly in chicago and take a 30 minute
puddle jumper to fort wayne so we took
the 30 minute jumper
yes but now now daddy
daddy uh had a 6 a.m flight out of fort
wayne back to l.a now there's no directs
let me tell you where you do be you take
at six am now they board at five right
so just leaving my body daddy daddy had
to wake up at 4am yeah
didn't get off stage till 1am yeah so
me mark my brothers went you know what
stay up we're gonna stay up oh and i'm
39 years old
and i run hard you know oh yeah and i'm
drinking on the road
now yeah yeah 24 hours up straight that
i didn't college didn't feel good no at
39 you want to die oh dude i was seeing
things my vision was my my speech was
slurred if it literally already you know
it's not good yeah it was not good and i
was like i'll sleep on the plane how
many whiskey's in i do too every show
yeah but you were drinking after that no
i never drink off the show or you don't
no never okay never never all right only
during stand up so you're not drinking
much no all right no no i joke around
but no um
[Music]
being up 24 hours and then because the
reason i have to get back so early
is
boston is obsessed with that car show on
sundays
every he wakes up at 5 30 6 a.m on the
dot
every single morning he used to say that
age you say ooh zombies and that's why i
have the zombie tattoos now it's papa i
want to go to the car show every single
morning that age every morning
every morning
monday through sunday we'll get back
from the car show he'll take a nap in
the car wakes up papa i'm going to the
car show dude
you gotta change the tape he's obsessed
with [ __ ] obsessed with the cards and
going around and seeing all the cards
wow loves it wow so i can't miss it
so you got to get up you're home you got
to be home by like a 12.
oh no
car show got pushed back which i got
your brother you got pushed back to 11.
so you know i left it at night
you'll sleep sitting up straight on a
plane because they're comfortable that
those seats are comfy couldn't sleep on
the plane because i was hungry too i
didn't eat i tell mark i i calculated my
head you know because i'm not hungry
before i perform while i perform at all
when you've done fort wayne there's
there's really nothing open for winning
right so i i would say
uh friday saturday i had maybe a
thousand calories a day when i
calculated my head wow yeah it's very
little very little barely eight i feel
better sometimes me too i had a meat i
had a meat fest my buddy's one of those
guys who goes
we're on the beach we play spike ball
play some volleyball i'm exhausted he
goes home when he makes when he
barbecues my buddy josh
he's a he's an
well he's a master at it well he's a
mess well hold on he's saying that's her
job
oh he's got everything but what how do
you cook the meat smoker
all of those green eggs smoked
grilled it depends on what what what
meat are you talking about sir the kobe
the kobe hamburger
that he makes himself from scratch with
his own spice blend or do you mean the
or do you mean the drumsticks the
chicken drumsticks where he's got dry
rub he's got asian barbecue everything
it's so stupid or how about the [ __ ]
barbecue pork ribs the rack of pork ribs
anyway the point is this is my favorite
i don't like pork i ate so much meat
with so much sauce that the next day i
woke up
well i woke up with the with the meat i
call it the meat eyes i call it the
meats did you get meat sweats you ever
eaten so much meat you start sweating
meat listen
i didn't have meat sweats yes i had meat
sweats all night but then you got to
take all the shits
yeah and then your stomach ain't right
bro no no so i had to i had to go i
fasted all sunday because i was like
that's just you did fast all sunday my
blood was great my blood was i touched
you and took uh you've never done this
you took an entire day to text me yeah i
texted him
when i was in fort wayne hello brian
yep i always get back a complete day
later what's up i went too late
i said do i text you 24 hours yeah
what were you doing jude i was you're
busy with your new friends i was
recovering you have new friends
that's what's happening i was recovering
you have new friends
no i was recovering you have new friends
oh you'd appreciate this you know
because how many opportunities you and
all the comics give me when i was coming
up
this kid
after thursday's show big kid saw it he
drives down and um i get done meet and
greet and the manager is like hey uh
brendan uh meet um what was his name uh
jk jacob hey what's up and uh where did
you come from mangoes i i drove from
india i go how far is that and he goes
uh he goes out it's usually two hours
with his traffic took him about three
hours like a [ __ ] man he drove a long
way just to come to show and he's like
no i drove to meet you man i've always
wanted to meet you and you know i'm 22
i've been coming two years
and i go uh what do you do in indiegogos
i work at the helium i work security oh
cool you're getting up a lot and because
i'm trying it's tough two years then
blah blah hold on dude you drove three
hours yeah i go and what are you doing
after this he goes i gotta drive back i
go to work tomorrow
and i said and how long does it take you
back can any map questions like whatever
two hours and 40 minutes i said bro
i wouldn't drive five hours to hang out
with drake you drove five hours just say
hi to me because yeah i go hold on hold
on
i'll give you five minutes
and he goes what i go wait before i say
that how much time do you have
you know comics every new comics like i
have 30 minutes i have two hours of
material and i go legit dude i'm asking
this i'm not going to judge you how much
material do you have he goes
dead honest and this is when i knew i
liked the muse i have five minutes i
can't do a second more
he was at western that five minutes hits
i'm out dude that's a good kid i like
that oh right away i went i like him
there you go so i go uh if you come back
tomorrow i'll put you on the show and
give you five minutes he's like are you
serious when i get five minutes man he's
like holy [ __ ] yeah five minutes dude
come back he's all excited
it goes on my head i'm like oh this
could have been this might be a
nightmare because you've done it before
i've jumped forward does it work out
i've i would to be honest with you guys
it usually does not work out no
especially if they've been to a long
time it's usually not a happy ending no
usually it's horrible and you're like
all right well i tried and you never
talk to him again
kid goes out there crushes five minutes
about his dead grandpa and having a big
dick crushes it's right up my lane
hilarious crushes how big his grandpa's
dick is crushes
and but he's in the new condo that long
and i'll give him the red lights hard to
see and he's like in the middle and then
you see his eyes and he goes oh oh [ __ ]
he pans goes did i run the red light i
didn't see it he was well that's my time
toodles and runs off the stage which was
hilarious toodles toodles he gets off
stage and i'm i'm like hugging him
high-fiving them you can tell he's a big
dude he's like introverted a little bit
yeah and he's like what's crazy for me
man is he's like six months ago i can't
even talk to you i couldn't come up and
talk he was like that's how shy was he
i'm trying to get out of my you know my
comfort zone like i'm like dude
hopefully this is a lesson to do take
[ __ ] chances 100 if you didn't drive
here tonight you would have never gotten
staged 100
and i was like i'm sure because you're
not getting up as much you're probably
doubting yourself i said this should
give you the motivation to [ __ ] grind
it out dude and i said i'll tell you
what we're gonna do and so
he does so i go you want i was only
giving the first show i go dude you
crush it do the second show he said he
came like nope we get done he's like all
right guys i'm gonna drive back i can't
think enough i'm gonna hold on hold on
we have shows tomorrow dude he was why
y'all you want to do the mario's are you
serious or yeah i'll put you on tomorrow
and i said but how far is indy he was
two and a half hours i said now come on
dude you gotta get him in my car he's
gonna give him a room i said you're real
comic man he's like well i'm like let me
get your room so i get in this room at
this we passed this hotel that was sick
so i got like this dope ass room in like
the top hotel there at first he didn't
want to take it that's [ __ ] he goes
like thinking he laughed and was like
i'll see you guys tomorrow i'll drive
back in my head like this poor kid three
hours back home it's 12 hours of driving
two days so i go uh
i text him i go hey man why don't you uh
crash with us or uh i can figure out a
hotel for you he was no you could tell
you didn't want to like push him when
she goes no all good man i want to sleep
in my own bed i'm like get out of here
dude so i just booked out down something
like no don't leave
and so he stayed there and then
next day does show crushes
that is a beautiful weekend yeah
that's such a good thing that's a that
that feels so good for you when you do
something like that for somebody yeah
that's how i always feel like i've
thrown a lot of
a lot of spaghetti up on a wall you know
and sometimes something sticks and it
makes it all worth it you know let's
take a break for a second you want you
got nothing to do this weekend though
you come out to wisconsin at the
milwaukee improv i'll be there next
weekend i'm at the freaking capsule city
austin it's gonna be fun buddy you come
out i got two good shows yeah i'm
excited improv hurts great i think i'm
there in november oh yeah i can't love
it out there really news from milwaukee
is jeffrey dahmer my dad's from
milwaukee jeffrey and jeffrey dahmer so
we got that going forward alumni uh-huh
i'm in san diego this thursday friday
saturday come get some thickboy.com san
diego laugh factory some monsters this
thursday friday saturday get you some
thinkboy.com
listen at the end of the day you know
what i practice my french on my out of
the app right here on your phone me too
you talking about babble me too dude use
babel because it gives me real
information i can actually use to
navigate my way i've been trying to
learn spanish now for the past nine
years i have babble two on my phone well
you can listen to real conversations
like you can listen to real
conversations you can take live lessons
from people you can do all kinds of
stuff you can do vocabulary words it's
probably the best i've used a bunch of
apps to me it's i think the best
app you can use to learn a language they
make it fun they make it easy with babel
you only need 10 minutes to complete a
lesson 10 minutes your way to work you
want to learn a new language how cool
that is it's created by 150 language
experts wow yeah with babel you can
choose from 14 different languages
including spanish french italian german
plus babel speech recognition technology
helps you improve
your uh with your accent too because
it's not robots your pronunciation is
the accent it's not a robot
all right start your new language
learning journey today with babble plus
comes with a 20-day money-back guarantee
right now finally kid listeners and
viewers you can save up to 60 off your
subscription when you go to babble.com
fighter that's babble.com fighter for up
to 60 off your subscription babble
language for life i paid full price
ladies and gentlemen i could have should
have been 60 promo code fighter i paid
full price and so there it is
worth it though worth it b a b b e l
dot com that's babble.com fighter for up
to 60 off your subscription babble
language for life i love that [ __ ]
though man giving somebody an
opportunity like that i always do little
things like that where you just you can
you can find out a lot about somebody
you give them a tiny opportunity and if
they're five minutes early and they're
chomping at the bit you can just see i
just love hustle and i love hunger
that's what i love if i see hunger and
hustle on somebody obviously they have
to be talented some people are some
people are not that but if they're
hungry and they're they they got hustle
and and they they have a spark of talent
man it's it's a beautiful thing to
facilitate well he said uh he when he
came to the green room on saturday he
goes
i didn't think about it because i was
talking to uh
uh mark and my brother about uh just the
horrible experience we've had given
people opportunities and listen the
worst can go as they bomb and then
you're like all right thanks man and
then you know move on but he's like ah
what happens if i were done really bad
i'm like oh you wouldn't be here and i
said but also this was a double-edged
sword my man because you're young you're
22 you know you work a regular job work
with helium if you had done bad this
would have let you know to this isn't
for you and to move on if you have a
sold out crown for wayne and you would
have eight [ __ ] and that should have
been a green light to go oh this isn't
for me right and he's like i didn't
think about that way i go yeah so this
was gonna help you no matter what this
was me trying to help you no matter what
i was gonna say you like to throw people
to the wolves yeah but that's just like
somebody that me in other words hey bro
you gotta go back to the drawing board
you're not even ready for five minutes i
i don't know if i ever told you where
this dude he was [ __ ] always already
a little weird one of those venice guys
and he goes dude i i when are you gonna
let me do five minutes on your show you
know when are you gonna let me get up
and do something i'm like well you know
uh you know whenever and he just kept
asking me because i'm telling you i'm
crushing i do this most unique [ __ ] i
like i talk about what it's like to do
this and i'm like already i know but i'm
like i'm like all right finally i just
get worn down i get worn down you can
wear be out yeah
my wall is just crumbling break them
down that's it so i'm doing my own 40
minutes at the improv
and i say
damn
go this is no joke i go you know what
i'm going to give you five minutes same
as me you know what
[ __ ] it right i'm feeling good
yeah why not and he's like yeah and i go
just be there so i
i
i get there late as usual i'm not gonna
wait go see him
so i get i'm walking towards the thing
and there's a guy
who worked at the improv and he started
he's just doing this he's gone
hey dude he's shaking his head i go what
he goes that guy whoever he is
whoever you put on
he's dressed like an alien he's in an
alien suit i go what he goes he's in an
alien suit and he's talking like an
alien so i i walk in he's got an entire
suit on a bad alien suit with a hat
thing and like big eyes and he's going i
am an ai
i'm it already the entire crowd is just
going
what the [ __ ] is he doing did he have
jokes
like an alien he just talked like an
alien hilarious well it's the greatest
it's not for five minutes might be the
greatest bit of all time 30 seconds of
that it's a great bit if you're a real
comic if you're a little crazy it's not
a great bit it's just that you think
that that's somehow unique and funny and
it was
when i say it was watch this ready watch
this ready
you see how silent that is that's how
quiet it was it it for the whole time
but you know and for you it's almost
funnier to watch that 100 percent the
absolute bombs are the best worth the
story yeah it was worth the story and
also no one's been like oh brian kellen
show somebody that came out like hey
that was terribly like holy [ __ ] how
about that alien and then i'm assuming
you addressed it when he came out were
you like oh my god i want to apologize
for the alien invading the stage tonight
i killed him yeah because you have to
die for that dude at the mean great
because i you know i write a new bit for
every city and because uh fort wayne is
only like 60 miles from notre dame yeah
so i made fun of rudy and rudy is i mean
rudy's like making fun of kobe bryant in
la or making fun of magic johnson in l.a
like he is
he is their guy yeah
so i made fun of rudy and this guy the
meet and greet goes oh don't you know
man um enjoyed the show the rudy stuffed
odd ditch i hear whitening i would get
rid of that man i know rudy oh you know
uh daniel rudiker he goes i know dan and
he called that's how you know he was who
knows if he knows i know danny well man
and he won't appreciate this i'll go oh
man you think it was funny at all he was
i found it offensive i went oh man
that's too bad well it's a comedy show
right so i don't know daniel so this
this is just you know i wrote that in
the green room that's what it's four and
he goes when he goes again one
suggestion
stop doing it
i was like okay how about you you want a
picture no absolutely not all right dude
well my favorite was there a guy as a
guy he actually went on to be pretty
successful and he wanted to stand up and
i i encouraged him to do it and he uh he
came and did it and he was expecting the
first
joke see a big mistake for a lot of big
income is you think the first joke is
going to crush and then you're going to
ride that roller coaster and then when
the first joke doesn't do anything
because he goes something the joke was
something like if you're if you if
you're with a hooker and she dies do you
get your money back or something like
that and
no everybody's waiting for the next
thing but he was like and he goes like
this and i watched him go like this he
goes
i never forget he goes
oh he goes oh
and then he told another joke and it
died and he went like this he goes
i don't know i'm laughing he goes
oh no
on stage yes and the fans are saying oh
no yeah it was at a brewing company
that's like
the waters for sure dude it was so bad
well that jacob that jacob kid was like
yeah i'm trying to figure out like my
thing i'm like what do you mean he's
saying i'm trying to i'm not big on
social media you know i know as a
commentary social media he's like but
that's not my thing again he's kind of
introduced sweet [ __ ] kid but he
dresses cool like you know he had a
tie-dye shirt on some jeans he's a
sneaker head you know how to do a hat on
and i go no this is your thing here's
what do you mean i go you're your thing
dude right and he goes oh someone told
me i need to wear a suit i go absolutely
not jacob do not wear a suit a suit have
you ever been in the studios at like a
funeral cool leave it for the funeral
don't bring your suit on stage dude who
told you that's not 1992 no a suit he
was oh like john mulaney i go hold on
that's john
mulaney that's his thing that's not your
thing you don't copy his thing no just
not john like he's like this old-timey
vibe yeah that's his yeah
he's very but not [ __ ] hilarious i
mean it's doing it forever he's been in
a suit forever but that's his thing bad
example like but also like that's his
thing yeah you know like your thing is
like he looks cool like his thing is to
find his voice anyway just worry about
stand up don't worry about anything that
host was great too
his name tyler
mark alex eaton god i keep thinking his
name is tyler he looks like a tyler to
me his name's alex eaton he's funny dude
so he does like uh
tick tocks or like instagram posts he
was telling me he did one tick tock got
35 million views what
yeah because somebody told him hey you
need to be doing three tick tocks a day
so he said he made three or four day for
months you know which
you know it doesn't take that but like
you've got to appreciate that and he's
used it to make money and like he's very
strategic about it and like yeah you do
have to do that you don't have to market
yourself dude you know we want we
there's nothing to do right so we walk
from our airbnb to this uh like pizza
joint and we're eating outside and he
comes by in the in in this the fort
wayne city truck in a in a [ __ ] in the
whole uniform like you know the orange
[ __ ] vest and the hard hat on and he
stops
dude bro bro it's me alex you're opener
i'm like no i know dude i just saw you
last night goes yeah obviously you could
recognize
no i know it's you dude you're just
dressed different he goes yeah
what's he do he's he works for the city
oh okay he does like like he was saying
like he's a good gig he does like he'll
pick up trash and like fix the flowers
and [ __ ] wow but he's just like you know
how like brody stevens like what was
bros thing like what he always give out
the area code remember two or nine one
eight two one wait until i die yeah
eight one eight to hide eight one eight
tell i don't he's the exact same about
fort wayne
someone say something like what up and
shout out the hair coat of fort wayne as
we is doing tomorrow i'm like whatever
there is to do here remember he goes
i'll show you dude you never seen
somebody more enthusiastic about fort
wayne and he knew his [ __ ] didn't take
you where he took his cool bars
you know he did what he cars to this
place called the landing it's like the
only spot like restaurant stuff and then
he took us to the uh like triple a
baseball team stadium okay the tin all
right all right but he was
so fort wayne
so fort wayne but he was funny because i
was like how's comedy out here in fort
wayne that's his home club say thank god
for this club and you know i get up a
lot
he's like the senior is tough he's like
there's this guy and he says racist
stuff and where's the clown knows
i was laughing so he's telling me the
characters i'm like oh my god it's like
i would never want to sense
the racist cat clown guy and he said he
pulled him because i guess maybe he was
running that mic or something yeah it's
his show and he said
you know i'd never want to censor him or
anything but like i pulled him aside and
kind of said hey man maybe don't lead
with the racist stuff never saw him
again
like
i've had to do that with certain people
who are using like sure uh the f word
for gay and
really oh that's back in the day though
no not so back in the day where i'm like
dude you're just not doing yourself any
favors yeah no favors with that [ __ ]
it's a reality check it's not even
people offended it's like you're just
not going anywhere with that i mean well
i think stu if they don't have like real
material like that shock factor stuff
saying you know the n word the f word
certain words yeah will get a shock and
they think they think as long as the
reaction they're good you know what i'm
saying it's like oh dude there's no
longevity in this my man yeah like
people like oh but that's not that's not
a laugh dude right it's very strange
it's a little bit strange um i'm headed
to the uh home run derby tonight the
all-star game oh yeah l.a you know who's
going to be there kevin bay yeah i
thought kevin this morning
i'm gonna see kevin there you are i'm
gonna take tiger yeah that's awesome
that's awesome what is it just like all
the top guys the top boys
just hitting the home runs so i figured
for a tiger because you know a regular
baseball game for a
seven six year old yeah slow slow for me
but these guys just so they throw them
fast balls and they just knock it out
just perfect fast while straight down
the middle like it might be their
throwing coach and then you get a
certain amount of throws in certain
amount of time and then home run derby i
think the same guys won
you know three years in a row two years
in a row really it's like all the
superstars are playing
chin i wonder if homeboy is going to be
in it the guy the japanese cat yeah i
wonder if he's injured i don't know but
look it up
you'd be interested to see and then you
know he's going to want a jersey how
about yesterday right when i'm gone out
of town i come back it's a celebration
like we go to the car show i get them
ice cream i make up for the two days
three days i miss i take them to toy
store and do what the hell they want to
do you know we're in the toy store i
could t whatever you want man you know
blah blah blah using a toy in forever
you picked out a lava lamp
future stoner i was like what really
yeah but i had one as a kid
i loved it i had a bit like those big
ones i got from spencer's my aunt bridge
bought it for me there's an orange one
he picked out like this tie-dye one
god damn that's like david tells joke
where he goes you ever get high and
packed for something it's a bad idea
because you end up at your destination
with like you got a towel and a lava
lamp and an oven mitt it's like i can't
use any of this stuff hey chin go to uh
uh hormone derby lineup let's see who's
in there
i i know some of the guys
you're gonna i'm gonna have to get tiger
jersey i don't know who you get i mean i
know aaron judge is huge trout has been
hurt obviously the japanese dude is mega
star
so one is kyle
schwarber okay
oh i know pete alonso he's a beast i
like him
corey siegert i know him
a wan soto monster
jose ramirez okay
julio rodriguez okay
uh acuna akuna junior i think has won it
albert pujols is in it albert has to be
40.
wow does anybody in the uh mlp
play who's not from the dominican
republic just curious oh yeah yeah right
that little area of the world
dominican uh dominican latin like that
that um cuba yeah they they focus on
baseball crazy crazy but uh my
brother-in-law he's a baseball coach and
coach like uh he coaches kids that are
like travel teams like the real deal
and he said in college right yeah he
played in college but he was saying that
he helps like 8th graders and then he
came early because the the the coach has
to help out with like the ninth graders
he's like dude he's ninth grade he was
like
oh are these is this the professional
he's like they were enormous they're
[ __ ] huge they play year-round
they're [ __ ] enormous there was this
13 year old picture he was like i
thought it was the yankees yeah there
was this 13 year old pitching i could
not believe he was 13. he looked like he
was just a grown man [ __ ] huge you
know what's interesting is that the mlb
draft might have been yesterday or the
day before but the top two guys are sons
of former mlb all-stars that's how it
goes there you go that's called genetics
a lot of times yeah
you just sunday yeah it was sunday
you know yeah they're they're daddies a
lot of the draft picks have family
already and were former yeah makes sense
that that makes 100 sense you know
it's like if your dad played a
professional i told you i played uh my
kids play tag with uh
two kids who whose parents were she was
a gold medalist in freestyle swimming
sprinting and he was a gold medalist in
downhill skiing now they're probably
attacked very much these dude these kids
i'm well i'm not joking they were
so much faster than my kids and they
were quite frankly as fast as i was oh
yeah
they were good-looking kids i mean i'm
sure olympics
two olympian parents just weird genetics
dude i just couldn't believe how [ __ ]
fast they were either could my kids
my kids are normal my kids were like
they're so fast i was like what those
are running what's that playing tag oh
playing tag
and these [ __ ] eight the kid was
eight and the the girl was probably
11 at the time well maybe younger ten i
i was so shocked do they have freakish
proportions it's usually swimmers you
know what it is fast switch muscle to
the point where the the swimmer the
skiers uh sister i see this woman she's
probably
45 and she was in a dress
i could not believe her muscularity and
i walked him and i said excuse me i have
to ask him of course what do you [ __ ]
do she goes i'm a personal trainer i go
i know but what is your how how are you
this muscular she goes honestly if i
showed you pictures of me when i was a
kid i was just she was just a genetic
the whole family's that way the whole
thing looks like uh one of tiger's best
friends his dad played professional
soccer he's on a traveling team
and during summer camp right now and uh
last week i he came i picked him up from
school i was how was today he's like
good good and i was like what'd you do i
always asked what do you do and he's
like oh he played soccer
and i oh yeah and did your buddy josh
play he goes yeah dad me and uh two of
his other friends were the goalie and
josh was the penalty kicker would you
stop anything it was nothing
oh that's all he does though t that's
his thing it's just
his thing so you get a football out and
that's how you would be he's really good
for one like you get a football
he's not familiar with football but
you're not familiar with soccer so
i was like nobody stopped a single one
though he goes no for the entire half
hour he probably scored 50 goals dead
wow
wow it becomes readily apparent you're
just entire and then the entire goes
yeah i got upset because then he started
telling us where he's going to put the
ball
i'm like holy [ __ ] this kid's on fire
god yeah he's a freak but but and he
plays with the older kids tennis is that
way and if you if you
if you think you're an athlete you know
and you're going to play at a higher
level it's just going to be different
it's just different you're just dealing
you know why i've been watching as
gordon ryan just uh lately did you do
yeah just watching how
how slowly he moves and how how
easily he dominates you how he's going
to get behind you and choke you and it's
going to look like he's looking at his
coach kind of yeah he's the best
thinking about something he's the best
yes freak complete freak it's just so
did you watch yair and uh brian ortega
don't don't tell me because me don't
tell you no no because it's monday oh
that's coming
it was on saturday morning sir i didn't
see it but i'm saying yeah beat him yeah
yeah because i'm if you haven't seen it
it's not i was hoping you'd have a
different take so we could argue but no
because i i have a well i'm going to
make a strong point about yeah rodriguez
i think area rodriguez is the biggest
threat to volkanovsky you didn't see his
fight dude how did he look
um i mean he he had a speed speed
advantage
he landed some really good shots on our
taking you know our team is just so
goddamn tough yeah and ortega finally
got him down exactly where he wants them
yeah yair puts him in an arm bar ortega
has two
uh bad shoulders that he had surgeries
on okay
yeah ears the pressure from the arm bar
yeah
popped his shoulder out they stopped the
fight they all this is unfortunate such
a shame in my head i text the thick boy
group chat right away that's submission
hopefully
no they don't count a submission tko
doctor stoppage dko
submission
it's a submission
you popped his elbow out this is
submission
i'm sorry but if you popped his elbow it
would be a submission so if you popped
his shoulder out yeah it's because the
pressure due to the offensive act 100
percent caused the fight to stop that'd
be something so yeah rodriguez i guess
has been really working on his wrestling
because that frankie griffin i remember
you said he's just not ready for a guy
frankie they've royally [ __ ] him up
yeah his wrestling coach is izzy
martinez same guy who came who was john
jones coach he's had jackson's forever
he's out of chicago took two years
really off i think i don't know why i
was fighting with dana something was
going on but he's a he's very big for
the weight class he's tall
yeah and and and uh i think he's going
to be a nightmare for everybody
don't you or no are you no i think are
you not that hot on him no he's super
talented i mean kid's a monster i don't
think he beats volkanovsky i think uh
vulcanizer is too strong too smart too
experienced i think uh we'll see how he
does emmett who's a beast you know
that's who he'll fight next because
volkanovsky has to have uh thumb surgery
so he's out for the year
ortega is gonna have to have shoulder
surgery he's out there's no rematch
there so they're gonna do it in term
dana kind of alluded to it too he's up
for it an interim belt of yair versus
josh emmett and it's a monster so see
how he handles emmett yeah but
i just think volcano sees leagues ahead
of everybody and volkanovsky i don't
really think he's he's gonna entertain
it i think he goes up to 55.
fight somewhere of islam and charles
oliveira which they announced is in
september september chin is that right
that's a good fight
volkowski is putting himself in the fire
that's impressive just getting up there
with the big boys
that's going to be really interesting
yeah islam uh islam and charles oliveira
is it great oh my god that's a great or
or is it you know we'll see what happens
oh that's a great fight regardless dude
oh my god
october 22nd oh it's october i thought i
was in september it's so far away
it's not market chef man
it's gonna be really interesting
really interesting i can't wait for that
[ __ ] and by the way just meeting uh
chandler
uh hey man food truck yeah a great guy
smart guy
but much taller than i would have
thought i mean taller he's not taller
than the bigger he's not but he's i just
you know i just figured he'd be short
yeah
volkanovsky is somebody who i think is
fairly you could say it's 5'4 maybe but
chandler's at least i would say five
eight you know would you give me five
eight i don't know yeah maybe five but
uh but just just [ __ ] but again he's
small for the division still walking at
185
sometimes 190
back in the day not too much now yeah
he's he's on that carnivore diet yeah
you know he's he's spelling i guess i
guess i guess
most 55ers walk at 85 don't they
85 is pretty big you know there's a few
but most of them are not that big
now like the game's change a lot of you
guys are real professional now yeah they
just keep their weight down the whole
time yeah they're not getting that big
anymore yeah back in the day you could
get away with it now but short notice
fights be more professional when i asked
well i met him at the comedy store and i
said what do you weigh right now and he
was 180
you know
yeah so
ah that'd be him but remember he took
two years off yeah he was injured oh
right yeah right right but he stayed
yeah he's trained year round doing jiu
jitsu you want to be what 165
170
max out there yeah yeah yeah yeah
because 185 is a that's a lot of weight
to suck how about patty pamela was 210.
made a food truck fights at 55.
hilarious was he 210 yeah at least right
more than that he was made on my way and
tell you
you're you're bigger than me big frame
and stuff too right right big head
fights this saturday
daddy yeah ufc is he fighting he is
fighting uh jordan i love it which is
awesome
the guy that does the splits after he
wins you know no i don't know jordan
love it who's he fought
no big names uh
hold on do you recognize this guy yeah
he's fun
yeah
well all right
i mean there's rumors not that it's true
or anything but there's rumors that he
might be you know
flexible into dudes yeah i don't care i
hope he is if he is it's all good yeah
if he is it's all good if he
he looks like he's got a good sense of
humor i like that [ __ ] yeah he's a fun
wow it's a fun fight yeah uh-huh
yeah it's ufc london on saturday just
gonna suck all that weight huh
look at this
are there any gay fighters in the ufc
right now besides stare and tell
just kidding oh come on
i don't think i don't get the gay five
from darren tell them
[Music]
there's female gay fighters oh yeah yeah
oh yeah yeah big time yeah there's uh
probably 50-50
there are a lot of guys that probably
like dip their toe here and there i
don't think a lot i don't think it's a
lot i'm just saying dudes like they're
yeah i don't think they're in the ufc on
things a lot
did you ever get turned on doing bjj
yeah all the time i'll answer the
question yeah
yeah i don't i i wonder how many are
currently like in that like nfl nba
nba there's not a ton of guys
it's 12 a team
yeah you know
nfl you're looking at what 53 52-man
roster so you're definitely something
there
yeah it's interesting but yeah they come
out after the fact usually right
but i don't think there's a lot right
i'll tell you
for the raiders and then he came out and
then i know but i think as a gay man a
lot of times you're not if you're a gay
man you're going to want to be or you're
a gay kid right you're going to want to
be with people that make you feel more
comfortable and at home and safe so i
don't think disability with a lot of gay
people in theater that's probably
because there are
there are gay people in theater it's
like i found my home over here my
community over here at least i feel
normal over here if you're gay and
you're a young man let's just say i
don't think you're going to go to
football because you it's just such a
bro space it's such a heterosexual
aggressive guy yeah it happens but just
really you just know that you're just
going to be alone it's it's it's
intimidating and then imagine so many
dicks in the locker room what if you
can't you know but you're not thinking
that you're thinking what's the safest
way to kind of go about things i guess i
don't know
how do you have so much insight into the
mind of a gay man me i don't know
i mean you know
the guy i'm thinking of you typed up up
in the entire world uh just type in nfl
uh gay right let's not go through the
world right i don't need to go through
the full that's that guy who was gonna
be the first the
guy
that's right so he was on the raiders
and then he got released and the
narrative was oh that's cause he's gay
and then the writer's like that's dude
that's because he wasn't very good
that's exactly what guys are like yeah
cause he's gay
handsome guy
i'm just saying
he's all right long arm i wouldn't call
him handsome yeah kind of a you like big
guys you're gay
you're
gay yeah
yeah what if you got cuckoos who's like
trying to convince other dudes on the
team to go gay with them
so no he he i
his contract was up or something he was
a solid player he was like no punk he
was like i think big 10 like player of
the year like good player man
[Applause]
hold on chin scroll up what college did
he go to penn state yeah he was a really
good player at penn state
six was that six seven seven
275 what the [ __ ] was only 290 and four
eight yikes
21 not that impressive
what's that you only did 21 on the bench
hmm that's a long arm so bubbles
doesn't matter
harder no it's 277 pounds
yeah
that's not good for a d-lineman
was he defensive end
he still is he's still playing oh yes
yeah okay yeah he just the raiders
released him and then you know
hell yeah in college unanimous
all-american lombardi uh trophy winner
he won a bunch of [ __ ] defensive play of
the year yeah first team all big ten
like he was a stud man damn
really good player
started as a walk on yeah he's a monster
wow using a lombardi award for being the
best college football lineman or
linebacker in the nation
damn he was [ __ ] stunned
all right jim what do you got buddy
alrighty
let's start with
ricky martin so this is in news right
now so apparently his nephew is accusing
him of some sort of incest and sexual
[ __ ] off she was a seven month
relationship he said yeah oh no
with his nephew yeah but his brother and
i guess people are saying like the
nephew has some sort of mental health
issues
yeah that's right oh
okay and of course he's vehemently
denying all these accusations
yeah
i might be a little bit on ricky's side
here because that's very strange he
might be crazy that's him there no so
that's actually his brother crazy that's
ricky martin's brother yeah yeah and by
the way look at his brother here that's
his brother now oh what happened i don't
know it's so crazy
hold on go back to his brother
before that looks like a bodybuilding
show no yeah for sure definitely just
bodybuilding yeah
um
hold on yeah let's try to introduce
incest into the case and import in
puerto rico
yeah
uh go to the next one
wait ricky was accused of domestic
violence
wait
what
by who
uh someone he was dating before somebody
out there is married with kids he is
married yeah he's actually with someone
right now a woman
sorry
no i'm saying ricky's been up for a hot
tub no i know that i'm saying
the guy he was with he was having an
affair with
oh was he it sounded like he had kids
all right i'm not sure they have kids
they had they had kids in the marriage
uh
when ricky came out
that was that would it it doesn't really
shock me these days but everyone he came
out like holy that was kind of true when
he first came out yeah
yeah my girl was saying like in the
mexican like latin community is
devastating because obviously he's so
attractive in latin community different
than here so very conservative very yeah
she was like devastating yeah now wait
what did what did uh let me see what the
guy says jen
that that one the tmz so just so you
know there's no real details other than
there's sexual stuff and incest is this
his dad saying
no no his brother his brother identified
the ripped guy now yeah that's the rip
guy the ripped guy's that so the rip
guy's his brother so his son no that
guy's son no someone else's son so it's
his nephew as well so the brother's
nephew and his nephew so i'm not sure if
this is his sister's son or another
brother-son all right but yeah let me
see what he's saying one of his siblings
offspring here you go
it's all no it's all in like spanish so
you can't okay
eric says he's on the side of justice
truth by his rant here you can tell he's
defending ricky casting down into the
nephew whom he's ideas 21 year old
dennis sanchez he also says if the
allegations will get true which he
he's incredibly over the responsive side
should not be retribution but
if it's true he's saying yeah
rehabilitation versus it's weird
which is crazy
i know yeah rehabilitation when you're
banging he doesn't believe ricky did
this but then how old is the nephew
their affair happened when he was
younger than that if that happened
uh i believe it's enough she suffers
from mental health problems i i think we
have to wait yeah yeah
yeah my instinct is to say nephew to
like my instinct is to go i need more
info yeah yeah
yeah but they're saying 50 years behind
bars this guy might be a little crazy i
don't know and he's just saying i don't
know but but here's the other thing
you're not going to get that kid's take
because ricky martin's so famous his pr
team's narrating that's the guy that's a
kid yeah
god 50 years
but is it
for sure he had a sexual relationship
with him is that for free no no it's not
for a fact this is we don't that's all
accusing ricky martin of actually
showing up to the pad his pad multiple
times when he didn't want him there
stuff like that
i don't it's very interesting but yeah
and and kept on going like you'd have to
be crazy i know that's what i'm saying
ricky martin would be the one with major
mental health problems there correct
that's [ __ ] nuts but also
yeah he'd be the great my only thing
with this why would his 21 year old
nephew come out with i mean it's so
outrageous yeah that's what i don't know
man you know what i'm saying like it's
it's it's uh nuclear bomb [ __ ] it's like
i'm gonna [ __ ] go crazy and say this
you know
yeah if if this kid came over
if the kids don't
it's against that match for
livestreaming the vita loco oh my god
but if if this is true like
if this kid has a history of actual
mental health issues and lying and you
can trace this stuff you can find are
they saying he does
we'd have to find out see that's the
problem is when you go for someone as
big as ricky martin who is
worldwide yeah his pr team who he pays
50 000 a month to can control the
narrative and this 21 21 year old kid
who has nothing to be tough to get a
voice out
yeah but if it's a legal matter now the
police are involved he's the son of
martin's stepsister
oh so he's not even blood no so it's not
that that makes it easier well but well
it's the son of his so he's not so
there's somebody related and he probably
didn't grow up with him this is very now
the plot is thickening
nephew by marriage nephew by
because techn and if you just read the
headlines
that's not an incest is it
no it's still on the family line though
no it's not but no no i know it has
nothing to do with family but i mean in
the family line but not blood it
wouldn't be incest though technically
why would he do 50 years
if it is incest
yeah it's frowned upon
there yeah incest would be yeah yeah
like that yeah now um but legally like
it's not incest right yeah you wonder
did he know him ever did he just meet
him the whole thing is [ __ ] weird man
but so if it's a stepsister then he's
related to the person that
look what if his so okay let me ask you
this let me ask you this so you're a guy
you're a single guy you're 50.
you're uh
you have a step sister
that means my brother that i grew up
with hold on my brother married a girl
right that's what no that means no i
mean your parents got divorced
that means your parents got divorced
your dad got remarried when you were
friends she already had kids
sister all she had zero okay
watch this so so your dad gets me
remarried when you're 40.
gets remarried to a woman i'm 40. your
dad gets remarried wait how would this
work so you mean now
my dad were to get a divorce get
remarried and there's another 40 year
old steps your dad gets remarried i know
i know what it is your dad gets
remarried to a woman she has a daughter
already
okay
that i just met for the first time and
then we hook up that's not insane no the
daughter then has uh
a child i don't know how this works
because the nephew is
that you're right you're right right
keep going so she's you've never met so
you that was 21. no no so the stepsister
is technically um
well no your dad would be married your
dad married somebody and they had a kid
from another marriage
so that's automatically you don't have
any connection that's awesome okay
then that stepsister has a child who's
like 21 22. yeah let's say 24 to be yeah
and and and and uh you know and then
they're gorgeous and yeah it looks like
halle berry and her 24. and now you've
just met her and now you guys and your
emotions are running hot and you have no
blood relation whatsoever and you end up
getting together it's gonna be weird
is it weird or is it just an
inconvenience it's weird with society
yeah but because it's also the only
reason that
i don't mean to erupt but the only
reason why it's frowned upon is because
your dad and this lady you don't know
agreed to a contract from the government
but there's no bloodline in any facet
that's what i'm saying
that's what i'm saying if it was my
person like my soul mate i don't give
well
it's dicey
because if the nerve gets out goes yeah
brendan married his [ __ ]
niece
give me a weirdo
it's give me a rough go for it that's
your step nephew
that's your nephew technically
by
marriage it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter like society's eyes is still
foreign three times removed i get it
brother i'm with you okay get a pr team
come out ahead of it
there's nothing coming out that shape
you know no you no you could you can't
come out at all you'd have to keep doing
the reps if you're in the public eye you
don't say anything
there could be like a super good pr team
though weird well
there's no way to defend it can we look
at the priority
what i'm very curious as to
it's his step sister this is what i did
ricky martin's steps
like a story the story is just like
love knows no labels right
and it's like the story and then like at
the very end it's like this whole story
about how madly in love with your and
then
by the way it's his niece i got one
better for you oh i got one more yeah i
got one better for you okay so your your
father
gets remarried you're single your father
gets remarried
what is this i don't know this is the
first picture that pops up that's his
family that's the dad
that's the two
uh
that's the brother that we saw who
changed a lot yep and then the other two
he looks like sure none of them
yeah
they all look kind of that step sister
they're like very tired they have bags
they have dark circles yeah that'd be
the step sister uh on the right
the only girl so yeah yes come on so she
had so she had a child yes
and that stepsister was the result of
dad having another woman when he got
depressed
but that's not blood related no there's
no blood relation
let's see this one
it's interesting okay so it's frowned
upon no matter how you paint but okay so
you're you're you're now your age oh
yeah it's your dad gets married now you
know dude he's got a kid yeah your dad
gets married to a woman she's got a
gorgeous she's got a gorgeous daughter
like yeah he said that that's now your
stepsister
are you allowed to have sex with her no
why not they just got married you just
met her it's frowned upon dude that
you're technically your stepsister so
you're so you're not allowed to just
because your dad got married to her mom
at this age that's the them you're fight
what do you mean hey them the rules no
i'm saying [ __ ] those rules really she's
your soul mate you met her you love her
okay go on instagram say i just made my
step-sister you guys just got you just
met
you just met and now you can't marry her
no that matters you can't have sex with
her because your dad married her mom
are you [ __ ] why aren't you fighting
with me here because i'm telling you
that the society is not going to allow
that you to flourish
i don't know if you can legally marry
your step sister i think you can let me
look it up right now
[ __ ] that i don't think so
i bet you can watch this
there are currently no walls against
them yeah
there it is
this is because while you might be
relaxing your step sibling through
is it okay to have a relationship with
your step-sister we all know that some
might think they're described as
questionable but you aren't related by
blood so by law you're not forbidden to
date or even marry truth is
relationships as you describe are most
often frowned upon when the kids are
raised as siblings i'm talking about two
adults yeah you're trying to talk about
just meditating you're just mad you're a
[ __ ] you're you're a man you've been
busy getting like who the [ __ ] is that
your dad just got married you're at the
wedding you're at the wedding yes your
dad got married you haven't had time to
meet the family
he shows up with his kids you're like
whatever they're my age
they're my agent and he has a 30 year
old daughter who's a [ __ ] smoke show
you guys need sparks flies no i do what
i go brian who's that yo-yo
sorry i hear what you're saying let's go
get a drink and then i go like this i go
can i can i have sex with your sister
she's eyeballing me
yeah that's not my sister because i go
like i go brandon i know you have a
thing he's your brother and he's gay
yeah that's fine no no i would literally
be like dude yeah i don't give a [ __ ] i
don't know her i'm asking you she's the
girl of your dreams you talk to her
she's [ __ ] it's me personally i
wouldn't care but
society's never gonna let you live it
down you're gonna have to keep it up
you'd have to explain hey guys we just
met it doesn't matter
society just sees brian mary's steps
would you get canceled for that on
social media what would happen
you're getting a lot of hate
are you yo yeah
you give people a reason
they're looking for any reason what do
you think jen of course yeah there's
really no fun way about it i'm just mad
at the wedding i'm gonna get a [ __ ]
break here but know how good good the
connection is it's just too much to deal
with i wouldn't want to do it no [ __ ]
that if that's your person you have no
control over it [ __ ] everybody
oh you're saying like you would go for
100 if that's like my soul mate and
we're not blood related i don't give a
[ __ ] about it i mean if there's an
amazing like undeniable connection to me
that's what we're saying i i don't know
but you're single right i don't want to
deal with that stuff though okay forget
that just single forget that right dude
you're at a wedding you're still going
to have sex on this on the sly if you're
both really attractive on the slide yeah
on the slide she's a f that's what i'm
saying you're gonna keep it under wraps
yeah but you're doing it
probably yeah hey dad turn a blind eye
don't bring that
you know what are you doing we we we're
into each other hey dad i know that's my
new step-mom but is she a freak like the
sister because that's this is a real
tomcat there you go hey we going on a
family vacation soon or what my favorite
case i mean double date
yeah
that'd be
dude you would get eaten alone you know
that happens all the time though i
guarantee i don't think all the time oh
keep saying all the time lately i am
i don't think all the time right be the
exception people marrying their
stepsisters i had a i had a giant family
reunion about
i don't know 15 years ago uh and i i
could i was astonished at how
good-looking some of my cousins were
that i've never met hey ricky martin
i've never met hey hey you should be at
this hey ricky martin take it easy i'm
not saying i was i just was astonished
at how attractive they were yeah they
were they were gorgeous i was like
pretty kids i even had to say something
i was like oh that's even weirder how's
this side of the family that's good
looking cause my side of the family ugly
they're just not good yeah sure i mean
i'm just being honest i know i've been
there i know i've been there
right
look i got eyes right i'm just telling
you nobody's winning a beauty contest
including me it's just they're they're
or should you enter no sure aren't
demanding you guys enter these contests
i don't know why i went to jerry
seinfeld voice there nobody's demanding
i told you if my baby i love my baby my
baby's so [ __ ] cute six months old if
babies were for sale
hold on if babies for sale though my
baby
is a standard model
he's a standard model not going for high
demand you're saying he's just your
standard model sure there are some
babies you see them and you go well
that's that's crazy gorgeous yes you get
the toyota camry of babies that's right
i'm gonna blow your hair back
cute as [ __ ] still a baby dollar she pay
all her but it's not he's not gonna be
on the he's not a gerber baby right
no like if gerber's having auditions for
the new gerber baby
he's not in it he's not in it no no no
he's not even in line for the audition
this is correct yeah and that's okay
that's the light that's life standard
model my baby standard model now you got
toya camry for kid let me ask you this
right now we don't know he might he
might be a late bloomer put a on a toy
camera maybe if a baby's now you can buy
a baby you're talking about slavery
right now i like where you go you can
buy a baby
and it's a weirdo angelina jolie and
brad pitt
they have a baby and there's the baby's
there do you does that baby fetch a
higher price and do you pay that higher
price than your kid
than any baby do you get the celebrities
angelina jolie and brad pitt have uh
their baby and actors two actors two
attractive actors have lady gaga bradley
cooper have a baby yeah like babies can
be handsome and sing yeah do you take
that baby
over my blood over and under over a
raise you have to stand my stomach i'm
adopting no matter what yeah so there's
a standard model or or you can have that
one do you pay the premium price
you do yeah see i say no why because
celebrities usually have disappointing
kids
typically
not really typically the kids don't work
out that well i don't know it's like
it's like kids who come from very
wealthy families it's like
it's tough for them i don't know if you
can say about celebrities there's a lot
of celebrities who kids [ __ ] crush a
lot of celebrities whose kids don't
crush it what about angeline julie brad
pitt i don't know about that they're as
far as their kids because they've
adopted so many but then they do have to
they i think they have some natural
sitters though but then uh what should
we call it jason momoa's stepdaughter
what's her name she's in [ __ ] batman
oh yeah her dad's lenny kravitz or mom's
homegirl steps his real daughter right
no no that's lenny kravitz's real
daughter it's not jason momoa's yeah
that's there well lenny kravitz and lisa
bonay that's a pretty cool thing the
kids so talented or the girl from
stranger things ethan hawks and uh hold
on uma thurman's kid can you go back to
that whole family so that's clearly the
white kids are clearly angelina jolie
very good brian yeah i mean hey
the asian kid isn't theirs
oh my god dude you're on it today well
those kids those kids couldn't look more
like a combination of those two
right yeah and then you have an asian
kid who's just two of them they adopted
a 40 year old from vietnam i don't know
what's going on obviously an ethiopian
child right there they always get the
most beautiful and that gets then that
other kid is uh malaysian he's probably
i said malaysia that's not the world
sounds good now the uh the their actual
kids are
spitting images of brad pitt and julie
yeah spitting yeah the girl looks like
brad pitt the boys both look like their
mom yes
yep dude do you remember when she was
dating billy bob thornton yes i do and
they wore blood around their necks yes i
do have you ever left somebody so much
you wear blood around your neck no i'm
into that [ __ ]
meaning you're showing to the person you
wear their dna blood sampling why do you
drink their blood
do you know the uh the tall
biological child in the other picture
is was born a woman what happened girl
oh they have a transgender kid she's
officially transgender but like dresses
as a boy
[ __ ] christ how much i mean this is
the social contagion i don't buy it why
does hollywood always have to have a
transgender kid well what a surprise i
don't buy it i don't buy it i think it's
a social contagion would you say
the kids so i have a friend who has
daughters
one of them identifies as transgender
but she's she's a young kid i think
she's just i don't know like
eight nine yeah it's social contagion
dude it's just that she's probably
watching stuff on the internet and wants
to do something you know that 80 percent
of kids who are identified as girls boys
who identify girls end up being gay it's
just a phase they go through yeah and
now and you have people that are saying
oh you're a girl so let's let's give you
invasive their their son there's killing
it though
the one the little white jacket that's
crushing it yeah handsome looks like the
mom and dad
crush it yeah i don't know where where
is there's a kid they have a transgender
kid
i don't think they've ever claimed to be
transgender basically
she would wear boys clothes kept her
hair short that might be changing in the
recent year like yeah
that's a lot of girls are like that i i
mean
yeah well you always call them tomboys
when i was yeah i think she like i just
looking at recent points his daughter's
gorgeous though their daughter is
gorgeous is that their daughter go back
which one
go up
right there in the middle
the middle no the next next one over to
the left to the left yeah right there oh
very pretty girl shiloh yeah smash
that's like she looks just like both of
them
that's that's winning the genetics
genetics right there wow well angelina
jolie looks crazy they don't get along
they don't get along oh they're suing
each other brad's suing us because she
sold their rose is the best rose i've
ever had oh it's actually good it's the
best rose i've ever had and you know i
love wine they have a great thing going
with that i think brad pittsburgh she
sold it to that guy yuri she sold it to
i guess this russian dude who's um he's
one of the first investors in uh
facebook
and it was just a really aggressive
thing to
do yeah
and he's suing her over that wine right
uh she sold it yeah and she stole it
without checking with him so she sold it
to a hostile buyer and they were both in
on it yeah and he put a lot of work into
that i'm sure and he's like what the
[ __ ]
yeah that guy owns it yeah she's i'd be
pissed too yeah i would imagine she's a
pretty
nasty person to have mad at you
wow
he's come out and said he struggled with
like vodka and [ __ ] though
uh yeah he also can't recognize uh faces
i think yeah because he was drunk all
the time
i think he was handing him the vodka mr
b
do you think you were drunk and can't
remember people or do you have a
condition but you know how how in
hollywood there's always talk
i've always heard amazing things about
brad pitt from a lot of people nothing
but good things and angelina jolie
is probably a little bit more mixed
you could tell me she worships satan and
i wouldn't care yeah yeah i agree yeah
i agree yeah i'm like yeah cool but
she's she's a little bit hanging out
she's a little difficult
really yeah well i mean i don't know i
don't know honest brian what'd you hear
you're not at the same time she does a
shitload for charity
you know she's a about those kids yeah
she's about she's a badass person i
don't know what they're saying but i
said i'm saying nothing bad about her
yeah
because if she was here i'd be kissing
her ass oh yeah you would
i'd be like oh whatever you say and i'll
be ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
ha ha
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha cuz there in
that movie mr mrs smith that's where
they met yeah
great movie things got real steaming
jennifer
that's right yeah and along and and
anthony was like listen there are levels
to this game she was like no listen i i
know you're with a tv star right and
that's fun and friends was i i enjoy
friends
a movie star right i'm also angelina
jolie i'm also the most beautiful woman
in the world so suck on this tit suck on
this movie star tit there's nothing
you're going to do there's no you're not
that's
a legit movie star and and angelina
jolie at her prime bring her up in that
movie
in her prime what are you going to do is
that her or what's her prime with billy
bob
it's a good question it's a good [ __ ]
question but i mean you're not she's not
hearing a peep out of you you're doing
whatever she tells you
go to there where she's oh yeah yeah
yeah a brad there of course yeah look at
both go go look at her she's leaning
against the thing with that shirt that
shirt look look leaning against the
thing with the shirt yeah with the third
one there on top you're the worst chance
i'm not the one that's bad at
entertainment you said that i guess i
think sir that's 2005. now look at her
look at her now you know what and now i
got jennifer
are you serious you're not doing that oh
no nobody's doing it no no nobody but
but again but nobody think about that in
order to jump from jennifer anderson to
angela jolie it would have to be angina
like jennifer anderson's gorgeous yes
yes now her daddy and uh jennifer hansen
both in the business yeah both you know
silver spoon
it just happened to be both gorgeous
she's also angelina jolie is also
insanely talented oh my god she's one of
the best ever she's so good that's
aggressive but she's so good it is
though oh look at her
well i saw her in person when oh and she
was so daunted what are you gonna do
nothing no you're gonna break up with a
girl from france you're gonna throw your
whole life away for that that's like
that's like and i think she's all
natural she is dove davidoff would
always say love on that level is like
they should warn you because it's like a
drug it's like be careful that love
thing you could lose your house and it's
so [ __ ] dress legit you're not doing
a thing about that
oh dude no andrew what are you gonna do
oh oh that's what are you gonna you
don't have the [ __ ] armor right you
know what i'm gonna do or the weapon you
know what i'm gonna do take your whole
life and throw it out the window 100 and
then also if she goes hey baby this is
this is weird but i'm really into it i'm
a bottle of my [ __ ]
and it's in a um a vase yeah it's heavy
like it's a real [ __ ] not just like a
piece yeah it's a full dump yeah can you
wear the jar around your neck
all day i go absolutely a full dump okay
i have one i'd say absolutely here's a
real test and i want you to be seriously
like hang out but can i take the jar off
when we have sex no bring her back bring
her back up bring her back up this is a
real test
no the uh where she's just sitting there
with her
like there's that
wherever she is
okay although what you were on chin i'll
just go back and no no no no you're
right there right there far right far
right right yeah right there there you
go now she's right there oh god okay now
now look at me oh i can't we we've been
friends a long time
yeah we're friends a long time sure
she says to you baby
she calls me baby i'm bored
wait are we in a relationship give us a
background dude you're in a relationship
with angelina jolie yeah now i want
don't go with me on this just go with it
but yeah i need i really need details
there i'm in a relationship yeah okay
now now watch doing well then just go
with me on this okay we're going to
improvise ready just answer it yep baby
yeah i'm bored okay
i need you to i want i don't feel like
you love me and i want you to prove that
you truly love me go on will you do that
sure
are you up for the challenge whatever it
takes okay
so brian i know he's your really close
friend right yeah i like brian yeah
you're old though you love him though
right he's your friend love is strong
but yeah he's cool okay you have a
podcast with them and you guys have a
bond yeah yeah
and i hate i keep asking you to do it
for writing but i have to
hold on so
like
i've always had this fantasy of watching
a man kill another man with his bare
hands absolutely say less
i didn't even finish the sentence you
piece of [ __ ] show you with my bare
hands you piece of [ __ ] so you'd lure me
she's gonna pay somebody to take care of
the body and then trace back to me
easy i would look you in the eyes and go
dude i hate i i came here to do this
yeah i hate myself you lure me to the
house and then you would oh no no i tell
you no no it's gonna be funner for me if
i tell you when i'm there hey b what's
up hey i gotta kill you right why
did you you've seen my girl right yeah
dude everybody's seen your girl yes
angelina jolie bro she's gonna break up
with unless i kill you so you know you
gotta die right right and you'd be like
oh my god i'm like i know it's terrible
i'm gonna come over and you know i'm
gonna say you can be in an hour and
you're like oh my god i go you know what
it's me funner if you run so go ahead
and run okay so i've always wanted to
chase somebody ready for the twist yep
yeah you come over
you you grab me by the neck and all you
just feel is
three shots in your [ __ ] heart you go
like that and then she comes out from
behind and she goes thank you baby oh
yeah dude it was all the [ __ ] ruse
and like she's just like older guys yeah
dude billy bob she's got me with my
billy bob hand around her arm and i'm
like see you buddy we'll love the game
you end billy
billy probably comes out too and then
i'd use that i'm saying
as i'm dying to go enjoy those old
balls
that's good good movie all right good
thank you
what else you got all right no but to
just sum that all up
uh a it's creepy about your family and
then b i would kill you in a heartbeat
for her okay i want her to know that no
i know i know she listens to the show
she does she's a huge this was nuts have
you guys been to this place before i was
just there you were there okay it was it
was right after my show i dropped
special in april april like 21st
whatever i was there on the 26th april
26th comedy zone in charlotte being
brian i gotta call half half that's my
boy who owns that place what the [ __ ] so
it was an active shooter this weekend
someone just ran in there with and shot
one round
that's it
but i mean that's terrible obviously but
not anything like i saw this headline
was holy [ __ ] active shooting at the
economy zone i sent to all the comics
like holy everyone's holy [ __ ] when you
look into it's like they're
like right now the media is labeling
anything mass shooter and you know uh
the the the mass shootings everything's
mass shootings now just triggering it
scares us right
and this one got me because like oh [ __ ]
there's some active shoes at the time
zone sounds like some guy ran in before
a show fired one gun ran off and they
got him still scary sounds like a crazy
person that just did something but this
is a craig robinson
there was an active shooter
in the comedy club
so they moved us over to this there's a
concert going on craig's the nicest guy
right such a good guy wow scary right
yeah that's [ __ ] scary man they
caught the guy but the guy didn't shoot
anybody just fired again around here
yeah people are crazy
yeah
and this wasn't just a quick one this
was in vegas i guess
a glass door somehow broke someone
probably like hit the glass door but it
caused this in like crazy ass stampede
everyone's on edge
oh because they thought it was guns yeah
that's good
yeah man the people start stampeding
there's all these active shooters you
know vegas has a history of it with the
the country yeah the country festival
thing that was terrible but so anyways
just one little
glass door breaking caused this entire
stampede listen i get it i was at the
mall with my kids and glass broke i
would assume the worst and jump over the
[ __ ] counter you know and when the
brooklyn bridge people the first time
they were walking across the brooklyn
bridge i think it was finished in 1885
and they were walking across the
brooklyn bridge and somebody a woman
slipped on some stairs all she did was
slip on some stairs some people fell
and people and somebody said the bridge
is collapsing
so everybody started running to get off
the bridge and 12 people were killed and
21 were injured and stuff like that
stampede and then nobody would go on the
brooklyn bridge and they got pt barnum
to take 25 elephants and like 15 camels
and walk them across the bridge and
people were like oh okay it's safe tight
move yeah yeah moving move yeah
yep
yeah i don't want to go to the heavy
ones right now but okay so this one
don't yeah do some light ones right here
what's up
i bought my husband a sex doll that
looks just like me now we have three
symptoms wait yellowstone actress what
is that about so there's more for
brandon because i don't know who this
she wasn't that big she was the
lawyer for the native americans on the
show she's barely in it yeah she's very
pretty but she's charged with watching
so
it's disability so she says she couldn't
work she got injured at on on a set but
then she ended up working right after
that so she's collecting disability
checks yeah this is a level of
intelligence do you really think you're
going to file for a disability and then
work and get away with it oh she's
gorgeous i was in 2005. yeah she was
super happy she's a little thicker now
yeah she's different oh that's 2005.
yeah 2005. yeah a little thicker that's
her as pocahontas all right well
so about a hundred grand worth of
disability checks but then that this
happens all the time those insurance
companies have people specifically that
go out to make sure that when you say
your back is bad they will go and watch
you on a saturday night and be like well
you are dancing so what's up those
people that literally that's their
entire career they if you file insurance
on that stuff yeah they'll go they'll
follow you if you pull i know a guy who
travels he flies around the country with
that he he has a camera flashback my
father-in-law he you know his
disabilities back in on chp and uh i
always go we got to get your back
stronger and you all get your personal
trainer and then he called the insurance
they're like don't worry if you work out
this all goes out the window
trust me they're gonna come by and see
if you know you're not working yeah if
they catch you working out all that
you're [ __ ]
i was like really yeah to try and
improve you even though you're not doing
like back extensions and dead lift just
to heal your back she's like go to a
physical therapist don't go to the gym
it's going to throw out this case 100
yeah i bought my husband a sex dog
you know i got to tell you i'm not into
it yeah
also like so you're going to bring just
some sex doll in there
like that's what it takes
just having a big piece of rubber
doesn't look just like her though by the
way the sex style looks actually more
the sex doll is a better nose this is
all done for better boobs too i know
they're both insane right it's also done
for content
is it though okay and they have these
things sell
the sex doll sells yeah they're they're
expensive too but a lot of guys use it
but also if you're they're 23. if you're
23 in a relationship and you got to
bring in a sex stall yeah marry your
step sister correct
correct
that's how you bring it back that's how
you bring it back that's just a deep
call back dude um and he's 28 she's 23.
she's developed feelings for the dirty
doll he's not just a doll oh you're
crazy we're really attached to her she
helped strengthen our relationship and
set our sex lives on fire wow really
the horny husband also why you all call
him horny the horny husband also
proposed the idea of threesomes
um
they did it
you go down more
that's all good the the doll also has a
giant that of hooters yeah it's so
different than it's not exactly like
yeah it's like oh this is exactly like
you no what you but when that causes
issues like brian let's say your girl is
like hey babe i'm just so tired i don't
have sexy one can we order a sex doll oh
yeah let's let's build it like me
right and then you're building it and
she's like why does it have triple d
tits i don't have those they're like
that's just what i'm into
why is that a giant ass i don't have a
giant ash like that's what i'm into yeah
why does that have a giant nose look at
his toes this looks weird those are some
weird toes oh damn
some janky what if he's claims he
ordered it he's like i ordered i told
him to make it look just like you when
it comes to giants they just [ __ ] i
just think it'd be great if that doll
had a huge dick
maybe it does seek a dick something for
both of us
skinny legs yeah and once you judge your
man if you just see him
going to pound town on this plastic doll
yeah the whole thing's weird she's she's
got a booty on her i don't think that's
real though what do you mean you don't
think it's real i mean like that's her
shopping shop what are you
yeah because her nose is wider big nose
big ass yeah let's see
oh you went to a profile yeah it's
taking a little while though
yeah finding a sex though but my thing
is
this is the road i'd go down like this
sex doll is fun right and she's like
yeah it's fun it's like why not try the
real thing
right like that's just gonna lead you
down the road of the real thing baby you
know we're [ __ ] with diet coke let's
get the real coke you had real coke
way better than diet yeah it is
oh this is her yeah
but she looks different okay well she
definitely has a booty on her she does
yeah she does a that's a big
can you please booty for accusing me i
just have to apologize unless she's
photoshopping every single picture
well john underscored wed too wants to
see her porn he left a comment twice
and then someone put you got bad posture
oh my gosh i would be willing to bet the
guy put you have bad posture doesn't
have a girlfriend that's so funny
yeah she's bootied up
yeah yeah that's cool too well she's
crazy you know
a little bit
uh this is an older one i thought this
was interesting it's not that high up
huh no you'll see you'll see yeah i see
it
hold on my computer's so slow right now
yeah you got to stop looking at all that
sex doll porn i know that's probably
causing this stuff to happen
a second here
the door kind of that dog can just
lunged out the window huh
it jumped from like a two-story building
how's your neck you never talk about it
it's actually a lot because i did the
epidural shot oh yeah and in february it
got so much better and i'm like better
and plus uh
mark's boy griffin he's been adjusting
me too so all right that's helping you
dr gaines griffin yeah dr gaines griffin
on instagram he turns your head
goes
26. i'm always afraid of that
oh here it is
oh my gosh
oh my gosh
oh my god she caught her dog
what if she didn't apparently because of
the loss
but again because of the lockdown the
dog got stressed out
the dog
does the dog work for an apple
oh my god but she was able to catch it
perfectly what if she didn't you just
didn't even see it coming and all of a
sudden your dog splats on the floor
i don't think i think he'd been fine but
i mean also a dog would never jump out
of him it would have been so he was
impressed with his guys
now a cat i wouldn't worry about it just
wonder if dogs have the same ability to
catch themselves no the dog would have
been he would have been messed up for
sure yeah
because cats turn themselves into a
squirrel suit you know i guess yeah cats
just always land feet first i feel like
i i don't know
what's going on oh wow so this is the
new nine nine nine two gt rs
and it's a small little quick video but
that back end is filthy this is what
that's on the road here
oh my god who's is that i love the
bumper
and the wing is in it's like insanely
huge that gets you crazy right there oh
yeah that rock hard why
that thing is sick but but like
the new the new gt3 rs is faster than my
gt2 rs oh okay yeah by how much i don't
know yeah
like like like yours goes 200 and that
goes 223 or something that's probably
like zero to 60 mine's like two three
that's probably two one or something
like that oh man i know point two
seconds but you still get crazy over it
oh [ __ ] yeah i love that thing yeah well
you like that so hard to get more
because they're just hard to get
no my they don't make the they've made a
new gt2 yes in a hot second i wouldn't
trade my car for that but i love that
jay's gonna be
foaming at the big dick for that
wait i saw something about a comic there
yeah this is a bill bird joke that i
thought was super funny but then my
computer's just from his special no this
is an older clip
about one with no means no
you see you guys seen this right no
means no that's another one no means no
it's like no it doesn't
all right
no means no no that means no all right
but no stop it what are you doing you're
being so bad stop it
no
such a good bit yeah no me he has a new
special he did that red rocks i know
bill sold out uh the green monster in
boston where the red sox plays listen
i'll be at the milwaukee improv this
weekend guys just as good as boston yeah
i'm in san diego brookfield wisconsin
milwaukee improv this weekend july 21
22-23 then i got austin texas cap cities
july 28 29 30 i'll be seeing our boy joe
rogan on thursday nashville tennessee
zany's august 26 27 come get some
uh go ahead buddy what do you got uh
wednesday night i'm the hollywood improv
shop and friends we got anthony jeselnik
trevor wallace eric griffin a special
guest myself it's the late show this
wednesday at 10 p.m the hollywood improv
and then san diego la factory san diego
downtown san diego that is this thursday
friday saturday the boys will be there
uh david lucas justin we have some
monsters on that show in the uh san
diego lab factory and then august 4th
through the 6th is baltimore one night
in chicago den theater friday night 7 30
show chicago august 26th then i'm in
appleton wisconsin september 8th through
the 10th ontario california just got
announced september 15th through the
17th and i end september in uh boston
but this week san diego europe thursday
friday saturday
is that it be and finally get 3d will
drop the first episode tomorrow oh yeah
on the fire and the kid youtube we're
going to drop all 12 episodes and the
outtakes
once a week you're getting finer kid 3d
we finally got him baby this the final
kid we're out